Speaker 1: Remember that December 14th at
6:00 p.m. Eastern we'll be doing the next
David Pakman Show Viewer Town Hall.
It will be streaming live on our second YouTube
channel, Pacman Live.
Make sure you're subscribed there.
We'll take a break and be back with much more
after this.
Remember that you can join the discussion
on the David Pakman Show subreddit at David
Pakman dot com slash Reddit.
I want to look at a couple of posts that I
spotted this morning.
This this is really funny because this is
this is now becoming an ongoing issue.
This post, says David.
Your videos on YouTube no longer display the
number of dislikes.
I guess YouTube has finally rolled this feature
out.
Is there no way of opting out so we can visibly
see the dislikes?
I feel that having dislikes not shown may
lead some in the audience to believe David
is hiding the dislikes.
Oh, it's not.
It may.
I am getting emails, voicemails and tweets
saying, David, you coward hiding your dislikes
in order, guys.
YouTube rolled out this policy.
I did nothing.
The post goes on to say it creates an issue
surrounding a channel's transparency to allow
dislikes and negative reception.
I know David would never try to silence his
audience in this manner.
But this decision by YouTube may have a blowback
effect on channel like David's, with people
commenting Dislike.
Or why did you remove the dislike?
It's not that it may.
People are already saying, why did you remove
dislikes?
We have no control over it.
This was a YouTube decision.
I could not care less about it.
I already was never looking at the dislikes.
I actually could.
It's funny.
The about a month and a half ago, I was looking
through our video manager and I saw you could
rank videos by the percentage likes.
And in general, our videos have like 95 percent
likes or something like that.
And I was like, Huh, I could be looking to
see what videos have more dislikes if I cared
about it.
And then I just moved on.
So the idea that I'm even looking at dislikes
is kind of funny to begin with.
But yeah, it has nothing to do with anything
we've done.
It's a YouTube policy, and that's basically
it.
Next post.
What exactly is this open border?
Does anyone know this argument?
We've all heard conservatives point to this
crazy, unruly open border.
That's Biden's fault.
What changed at the border?
I've never seen the U.S. under any president,
have an open border, and I don't understand
the argument.
Aren't we still deporting people and turning
them away?
Isn't the process to get citizenship highly
complex and lengthy?
I always hear people say we have an open border
and we give immigrants money, health care
and education.
Where exactly is that happening?
Is this all made up, or is there some factual
basis for the claim?
So the truth is there has been nothing, and
it's actually mentioned in a comment in this
Reddit post.
We've had nothing approximating an open border
of any kind for about 100 years.
There are countries that do.
Although I'm not up to exactly where it stands
right now, my birth country of Argentina for
a long time.
I'm not going to say it's exactly this way
now because I'm not sure, but for a long time,
anyone could basically go and assuming that
within, I don't remember it was a year or
two.
You either are able to get enrolled in a university
or are able to find a job.
That's your path to legal status in Argentina
now.
It's not like Argentina is the U.S. and everybody's
trying to go to Argentina.
Not that everybody's trying to go to the U.S.,
but there's a lot more people trying to come
to the U.S. than to go to Argentina.
But no, the post is right.
There is not an open border.
Even the process for requesting asylum is
not a particularly short or easy process.
There is no open border, and it's just another
one of these vapid right wing talking points
that works on a lot of people.
Lastly, David, Sir, if the Supreme Court rules
against Roe v. Wade, does Biden have a green
light to expand the court?
We can make the case that morally.
Joe Biden has a case to expand and pack the
Supreme Court.
We can make a case that legally and politically
he does, but I don't think he's going to do
it.
If you give me, as I like to say, I'm not
a betting man, but if you give me an even
money bet, does Joe Biden add justices to
the Supreme Court?
I'm taking the No.
I think it's I just don't think he has any
interest in doing it.
If you disagree with me, certainly let me
know.
And you can join the discussion at David Pakman
dot com slash.
Read it more than where we're around, I think
33000 of our viewers and listeners are subscribed
to the subreddit.
Great place for respectful discussion of politics
and news.
David Pakman dot com slash Reddit.